welcome to this video against clear blue
water no I no name he's an IM but oops
let me get rid of this but no name in
there I played him one time and one of
the game oops so on go for my seviche
line check let's see is he going for the
absolute main line seems to be the case
98
yeah f5 is the normal reaction and let
me think about this Abby should be three
first I keep forgetting the exact move
orders him I wasn't 93 okay
yeah that's a typical position from the
from from the sameish main line here a
very M double edged position of course
we're wide is suffering from this
problems on the queenside and hopes to
get some some play against the king try
to use the e-file here Bishop e2 f2
possibly later to H form he can play
Knight a fire but well that's life in
this opening I actually have confused in
waters here it didn't wanted to play
this this precise position but now
there's not much not much to do that
should be three I think what's wrong
let's let's see yeah it's no use in
really trying to defend the pawn that's
going to get lost anyway
this night is trying to reroute to e3 or
possibly d to f3 i also want to have
bishop h4 at the right moment for
example here Bishop edge for can can be
an idea but i also have 93 now covering
c4 for the moment and maybe making 95
possible I really not I really don't
know why it didn't take savoia it was
possible I believe this isn't ending 95
96
yeah maybe I'm bishop to be seven is
something that like you can consider not
necessary but comes into consideration
mmm that's interesting okay I'll put it
there i mean this was the whole point
I do know this this looks this does not
look right to me but not really sure how
to exploit it and move like g4s maybe a
bit too strong and medicine maybe it's
just the right medicine you never know
okay come on this opening is sir is
calling form for very drastic measures
quite often so let's go ahead here it's
may be totally bonkers but with but slow
moves I'm probably not getting getting
anywhere okay like you know it can just
take now I mean also Bishop e7 is
probably nine f60 pf6 mmmm Bishop e7 is
probably a winning some material but I
can just take can I isn't this isn't
this quite good I can take d 5 or take
d5 cd5 I know he cannot you should be
three I have f6 intermediate move chants
that's very important and now maybe even
rookie seven rookies seven chains tix I
can take here and at the end Queen g3
Wow what are we at position but do I
need to take the bishop really do I have
a better move
check yeah this seems right Oh came and
now looky aight i guess no why not
rookie aid okay yeah i thought he needed
to check make it possible to to take the
pawn conveniently okay Queen g3 is what
about this yeah not sure grilling at the
end the pollen on his 7s a bit it's not
clear that hide one so probably with
rook c8 he has in a way allowed that
and I can't play this with the rook on
the edge there will be just Luke take c7
and I have no idea what's going on and
then here um yeah I thought I thought
this is opening up most lines most lines
possible check yeah I know it needs to
go on the 1d seven probably and then
Queen III what do I have Quinn b5 HTF
couldn't be five may I can also take on
d6 or still could be five what is he
doing against that Queen d7 I guess then
I have bishop edge form come on let's
start with the movie
yeah this must be good really are isn't
it um Edison isn't this winnings come on
check check quindi seven others chat no
not no no check he does not have any
chat of the counter play and now Queen a
six it's not winning
cannot believe I don't see you in here
all night night where the chances a win
last second win ball who
black resigns yeah that was a very fishy
game I guess I mean I was probably just
worse okay let's let's start from here I
mean there are things before that can be
considered i played this very very hot
move but not sure it's doing much yeah
very very tough he could have maybe
taken on c4 I think that's what I what I
would have done can I cannot maybe if
what if happens if i take on on f5 here
like an intermediate moves I can take d5
okay sighs I didn't see at all okay so
probably this and queen d three yeah you
know g4 looks really crazier maybe I can
come out of that g5 and 96 but it kills
my bishop it is probably nonsense this
line really deformity and here the
suddenly Oh didn't play right computer
prefers that okay yeah quite obviously
as he has to take with the night hmm
this I should have thought about and
this this is not helping and that's
especially not okay yeah then this is
much better yet he could have taken you
one but the computer also like this but
here of course you must take you first
yeah and this is just a winner this was
just a bad game you can you can easily
win this way check and hear me here the
computer is giving equal
but i didn't i didn't understand really
why not rupee 8 this looks far more how
more reliable something like that okay
Queen g3 emphasises player i am now yet
here's mr. had missed something earlier
but here here it gets it gets tricky
rookie one seems to be better and this
ok computer likes this as long not as
much but yet here here why does a witch
which does not surprise me but she I
didn't really check ok this is the win
yeah I found I found the win at the end
I wasn't I wasn't really sure and the
way and why I wasn't sure it's because i
had seen queen bee 7 and I was only
thinking about this yeah it also wins
with Queenie six but I didn't see I
didn't see I hadn't seen this ready I
know it's simple but I only had five
seconds and this would have been been
tougher of course he had so as a chat
made and a couple of moves and he
resigned he had you to lose checkmate
checkmate this checkmate checkmate or
this one so very dramatic finish not a
very deserved win really because I
played it hard to yeah far too far too
risky or whatever g4 is really a
reckless move what should I play though
taking here or 25 me I don't know
alright thanks for watching